one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday it's
unfortunate
but it is what it is and you know what
we're one we're getting one step closer
we're like actively starting the week
you know it's better than just like
waiting for it to happen yeah we're
starting things we're starting new
things new week anything is possible
this week you guys whatever your dreams
are chase them make them happen if you
got a chance take it
beautiful thank you if you have a chance
take it and that's the song that won
period country song
over Taylor Swift everything okay yeah
no no it's like I can't remember what it
won but it won something over Taylor
Swift last night I want to like the
appreciate last night pre-show Awards
what song is it Cody Johnson oh if you
got a chance take it it's actually
really good it sounds like a great song
with a great message
that's exactly what it sounds like that
is exactly what it sounds like
um so we have a great show today we've
got Grammy's recap we've got Bryce in
the building we're gonna talk we're
gonna mention it all yeah a lot of
Grammys because you watch the whole
thing I watch until Luke Combs performed
and so unfortunately that meant I had to
watch about
three-fourths Jinx or 75 percent Jinx
yummy soda you owe me a soda go get me
one you've been taking my sodas all week
you can't talk until I say your name
you've been drinking my sodas all week
so I've gotten you a soda you're not
respecting the rules of jinx no I'm not
I don't respect games that was like the
most annoying gameplay like to play if
you don't play yeah I guess it's not an
annoying game if you don't abide by the
rules no they don't exist jinx also
another annoying one was um when you
farted like safety yeah and then what
was the rules like if somebody said
something before you said safety
you couldn't talk you had to kill
yourself
no like what was doorknob or something
you know what I'm talking about I
haven't played dumb [__] games okay
but like you like we we abided by that
game but I didn't process the rules
because I wasn't playing so they're not
ingrained in my psyche you're such a bad
friend like friends play games with one
another and I do everything else with
you it's so true there's things you
don't do with me we spend the whole
weekend together we did and we my
friends were here this weekend it was
really nice we had such a fun
it's like really such a fun weekend but
also very wholesome you know aside from
like Saturday night when we went out
partying yeah yeah but like we cooked we
sat around we swam we didn't read which
was surprising for our crew but we
should have read instead of deciding to
watch the triangle of sadness I can't
even give that movie a platform on my
platform there's things that I can't
control in this world but I can control
what I give air to on this show
it's not it's not the biggest show in
the world but it's my corner of the
universe let me offer a rebuttal as to
why we need to talk about it okay to
make sure after this not one of you
watches it not one if you were thinking
about watching it do not zero zero zero
none
let me tell you why because I watched it
because and I'm really I'm calling out
my friend Abe he was like this movie on
his Instagram story it's like it's
basically he's disgusting it's basically
White Lotus and then I saw then after he
said it I saw like a bunch of people so
it's like the normalization of the film
I was like oh this is probably you guys
are disgusting anyone who saw the movie
and didn't come away being like don't
you dare watch that movie is a
disgusting person sorry it's so
it was so disgusting and like if you can
get Beyond like if you're not easily
triggered by like vomiting and diarrhea
which is just like kind of disgusting to
watch the movie itself is not good
either but like there is like literally
a 20 minute scene that is so disgusting
of people okay spoiler alert because
none of you are watching it now
um they get seasick they get like food
poisoning seasick there's a storm and
it's 20 minutes of people on the boat
different scenes of them vomiting
[__] diarrhea flowing from the
toilets all over the boat slipping in
like 20 minutes so vile and the way that
like this movie has been so discussed
like and there's just been discourse
around it and nobody thought to mention
the vile disgusting feces and like human
waste I'm shocked by the culture I
really am and the first half of the
movie is so boring but you think they're
laying the groundwork for a movie so
it's like okay I'll try and understand
like the Dynamics here and then I
actually didn't finish a movie but I
probably watched with like 30 minutes
left like 40 yeah okay that's when I got
up but I got to like the main point of
it
um and then you told me what happened at
the end and it's like nothing about the
first half of the movie is at all the
main to the second half of the movie
it's like why did I watch all that crap
crap crap I don't give a rip it was crap
so my journey of watching Oscar movies
like I'm done you guys it's a disgusting
world out there yeah my journey I
watched the menu and triangle of sadness
neither of them were that compelling I
do still want to see the whale but
that's it of course I'm done
I tried I can't relate you guys are sick
I can't relate to the cinema industry I
really can't it's not for me and that's
okay it's not for me anyone who saw the
movie
and that anything other than it's
disgusting to say about it like camera
light sorry couldn't be me maybe we'll
talk again someday maybe today maybe not
today maybe it's a big maybe but you
never say never like things could be
bring people together all the time I
will fight you forever
I will never say never I'm always the
only words I know those are the only
important ones so [__] true so that's
what we did on Friday night when we
should have been reading and watching
anything else Sam wanted to watch The
Sound of Music we should have listened
to her 100 frolai Maria would never
the baroness would never
preparedness doesn't diarrhea no so this
is just like we I feel you know I don't
take this platform lightly like I feel
like every episode you should leave with
a message or a moral or something and
today's is do not watch a triangle of
sadness like Trust and Believe like it
was infuriating in the ending I think
they were really trying to make some
sort of statement on like Elites and you
know the disparity between the rich and
the poor and like I get the message and
I think they actually do that really
well in White Lotus this was so like
exaggerated and unrealistic and
unfulfilling at the end honestly it was
[__] terrible yeah it was insane it
was an insane movie in the worst ways
possible agreed and now that like I've
tuned into the Grammys from start to
finish I feel like I've gotten like
satiated in terms of award shows like I
don't think I'll be watching the Oscars
yeah it just depends where I am in my
life but I don't it's not fun to watch
the Oscars when like you really don't
have a horse in the race yeah well if I
see the whale I'll have a horse I'll
have a whale you'll have a whale in the
race because with the Grammys last night
like we all had horses and none of our
horses won really yeah I have a lot and
they did their favorite thing where
everyone took home one award all the big
you know I think lizzo won an award
Adele Beyonce it wasn't a sweep when I
really thought it would be either a
Beyonce or a Harry sweet it should be a
sweep you know what was tops no like if
we're really kind of you know judging
the best then there is only one yeah and
make a choice
everyone wins I know you want all these
people to make speeches because it's
like good for your ratings but like make
a choice that's always interesting make
a choice I completely agree choices were
not made and the thing is it would be a
really hard choice I don't even know
what choice I would make between album
of the year with Harry Styles Beyonce
lizzo lizzo and Adele no the thing is
it's not not your choice to make that's
right that's why there's a whole ass
like company called the recording
Academy whose job no but it's not like
I'm saying like your Harry was wrong
right like I don't know really you know
I I you'd have to tally up the votes but
like someone should be sweeping yeah and
it's not the sweeper no it's not it
should be but it's not me so who would
you have swept
Harry yeah like it was whether you love
him hate him whatever you it's
undeniable that Harry's music really
defined this year and it was the whole
album it wasn't just one or two songs
from the album that's how you know like
an album really like people digested it
permeated yeah so he won I think like
two out of three that he was like a
vocal an album of the Year album of the
year is like the biggest the one it's
the it's a category that feels like a
real category
was an album that felt like a real album
do you think that when he gave us
nothing in that interview and then was
roasted for it subsequently that like he
ever knew that it was probably the most
profound quote of the year like it's
like when Kyle Kylie said like this is
the year of just like realizing things
and at first it goes viral because we're
making fun of it but then like we can't
stop saying it because it encapsulate
encapsulates everything and it is in its
own way quite substantial yeah like
although it was mocked for being you
know no substance inconsequential
but maybe the joke's on us we didn't
understand the deeper meaning
but I'm obsessed it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy because his
album is an album that feels like a real
album it does from start to finish it is
a cohesive work of art yeah so let's
dive in because we have a lot to talk
about from the Grammys I have so many
thoughts some good some bad and some
like I'm gonna like people need to get
roasted like
it just has to be done yeah yeah I was I
wasn't loving what I was seeing no the
honestly I'm in love it was like a bad
award show but it was good and enjoyable
because everyone showed up yeah everyone
was there but I also felt like the setup
like when Trevor Noah was doing his
monologue and he was like walking
amongst these little tiny tables and
celebrities like had to like twist
themselves and I was like you guys know
how to twist like that that's so
uncomfortable it was so human yeah but
it made me feel weird yeah even though I
think somebody should be like treated
like people because they are like the
big like Adele is twisting and turning
it at a bad angle with a big dress while
we look at Trevor Noah Oh and lizzo's
next to her like it was just weird yeah
no it definitely was weird and then Luke
Combs is in the background like not
knowing he's on television like I can't
stop staring at him so I will say I
don't know if this was done
intentionally but like they definitely
everyone was pretty vulnerable you know
everyone was vulnerable everyone was
pretty vulnerable in terms of angles but
then also terms of like they shot really
wide and like Trevor Noah was standing
you might have thought if you're a
couple seats over you're not on camera
but like you were and we saw your face
you know and they kept cutting to like
they're being shady with the cuts you
know if Harry was on stage it would show
Taylor like they were being um they were
giving the people what they needed you
know getting gen uh Jennifer Lopez and
Ben Affleck like on camera twice
fighting like they didn't know I don't
get that vibe from them I thought no
everyone's like he's miserable he
doesn't want to be there with her no
like they were cute okay no I mean I
found them to be cute they I found them
to be relatable
I didn't see them fighting I saw like
there was one time not during a song or
anything like right before a commercial
break they panned them Jen was like on
her phone but not in like a that's fine
not in a too focused sort of way and
like Ben was just like chilling I was
like that's a real couple by the end I
saw a lot of people on their phones it
was a really [__] I mean it was
supposed to end at 11 and I don't think
I turned my TV off till like 11 45 so it
was really long a lot of people were on
their phone didn't turn your TV off till
midnight you can only feign enthusiasm
for like other people's accomplishments
for so many hours yeah or at least I can
yeah so I thought it was interesting
let's get into our Grammy's recap and
the fast five stories that you need to
know and the fast five stories that you
need to know are brought to you by
manscaped roses are red violets are blue
our friends at manscape to have a gift
for you ladies manscapes are now selling
beard products that's right the leader
in grooming are revolutionizing the
men's hygiene game once again with the
new beard hedger Pro kit it all starts
with the beard hedger which is their
cordless trimmer that has a rotary wheel
with 20 hair cutting lengths and one
guard so there's no messy drawers full
of extra little clip-on things which are
so effing annoying if you hear that
there's no more messy drawers and he can
sculpt his look however your heart
desires to fully unlock his bearded
confidence this Valentine's Day even
better save 20 off and free shipping by
going to manscaped.com and using Code
toast so the beard hedger Pro kit is the
ultimate ultimate Valentine's Day gift
to give his Cupid an arrow from
manscaped so it all starts with the
beard hedger which is the electric beard
hair trimmer along with only having one
guard it's also waterproof so we can
shave in the shower to avoid those
little pubes around your sink which is
really one of the most annoying things
about having to be married to a man
um they also have the dermatologist
tested formulations like beer shampoo
and conditioner because beards are
low-key like really disgusting like food
gets caught in there
um so beard hair and shampoo
um is designed for more coarse hair
that's typically found on beards um the
kid has made shampoo and conditioner
specifically designed to moisturize
reducing grown hairs replace natural
oils and promote General beard Health
also the kit comes with a beard oil and
a beard bomb that will help shape style
moisturize and tame a first sculpted
look also comes with three gifts that
beard hedger Pro kit a beard brush comb
and scissors to ensure he has all the
tools for a perfect beard get 20 off in
free shipping with code toast at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use code toast
spice up Valentine's Day this year with
manscaped
um today's episode is also brought to
you by Squarespace
so excited that Squarespace is
sponsoring our podcast today so if you
work in e-commerce do you have a
business that relies on e-commerce you
have a side hustle whatever that is
really recommend looking into
Squarespace to design your Ecommerce
website if you're not you know a very
skilled and experienced website software
engineer it can be really hard and not
know where to start when you want to
create a website and over the years for
my blogs and stuff I've used many
different platforms and I don't really
know how to like back and build a
website I'm not an engineer in
Squarespace is fabulous because from
start to finish they've got it all
so they are the place to sell anything
Squarespace they have the tools that you
need to get your business off the ground
including e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace has been merchandising has
merchandising features to make your
products look their best online you can
also connect with your audience and
generate Revenue through gated members
only content you can manage your members
send email Communications leverage
audience insights it's all on their easy
to use platform
um so check out squarespace.com toast
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use our offer code toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain again that's
squarespace.com toast for the free trial
once you're ready to launch use offer
code toast to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain you
can really do everything with
Squarespace email campaigns you can
collect donations you can share your
social media you can get analytics save
different tools for blogging it's really
kind of everything you need to get your
business off the ground or if you're
looking to revamp your website check out
squarespace.com toast you won't regard
it you will not return regard
gertia says you won't re regard it I
don't know you'll work out I try next
time I tried uh first story Grammy's
2023 recap so
we'll go through all the winners I did
want to say Trevor Noah was abysmal um I
know it's a job like that nobody wants
and no one really does a good job but
like his jokes were so
like cliche and obvious almost corny
like hey harry like I love you in
women's clothing can I come on tour with
you like yikes
um he did though and I know I sound
crazy but he made a joke about
anti-heroes yeah and like like we made
that up did we not like not to make
everything about us okay we came to the
joke on our own like that was our joke
and I do believe he came to the Joker
episode like it's not the most original
joke we say that all the time when
people are like you copy me it's like
well we both have brains and it's a
pretty clear connection yeah that's fair
we're able to come to it on our own okay
that's fair so I didn't feel like he
took that from us but and I was glad
that the auntie's like I'm never gonna
complain when the aunties are getting
prompts representation you know no I I
like Taylor that joke reached Taylor
yeah she knows and she thought it was
funny she's really just polite everyone
was she's very well-mannered that Taylor
Swift yeah everyone was being polite
because like his jokes were really bad
like they were really kind of Elementary
like intro to comedy jokes they were
just so obvious no like I was watching
him and I almost like watching with an
open mind you know it's my Sunday night
I had like a a Haagen-Dazs ice cream
mini bar and I'm saying Harry was asleep
Strife was there we had heating pad like
I was ready to enjoy my life I really
went in like looking to have not to
complain like I didn't have my phone I
didn't have my Kindle out
um and my takeaway was that like he's a
big loser yeah and he was just being a
loser yeah and again it's it's really
not a job that you can ever come out on
top of so I don't know why anyone would
do it but you can like especially there
are people who do it and it's like we
don't hate that some people do amazing
few some people like doing well enough
yeah you just have to make yourself
scarce like I just feel like whatever
spares scares scares you said scars
scarce like you like you just do this
least and like bother people at least
and don't take up that much time and
like don't do anything so like
outrageous you really you're supposed to
blend in as the host yeah and he just
was not it was it was really not good so
I hate to be like a negative but he was
bad yeah um
now let's go through the the winners of
how we watched it okay best pop vocal
album Harry Styles
agreed best r b song Beyonce cuff it and
she was not there to accept because she
was stuck in traffic which was like
really shocking that they admitted that
she was coming and that she was late and
like she wanted like she meant to be
there but she like wasn't there yet
Queen
um I have a lot of thoughts on Beyonce I
feel first of all did anyone else feel
like ever so everyone was talking about
Beyonce like on the red carpet they're
like are you excited to see Beyonce it
was literary question who are you
wearing are you excited to see Beyonce
um and it felt very much like Beyonce's
sweet 16 like it was Beyonce's night and
it was because she was hopefully going
to reach this like historic achievement
um but like the monologue was all about
Beyonce and it did feel a little weird
just because like this was a room of
other successful people like supposed to
be celebrating their own accomplishments
but it was like and I felt like every
time they they spoke about Beyonce once
she arrived and they like cut to her
like she was getting [__] annoyed
like it's like it's kind of awkward
she's just these are her peers
technically even though like they're not
they're her peers and so to make it like
the whole night was about Beyonce I felt
like she was like embarrassed like
people were just like acting crazy about
Beyonce she's like stop like I'm just
here like everyone else even when Harry
um collected his award for album of the
year like somebody screamed in the dead
silent like it should have been Beyonce
and like it was awkward apparently in
the stadium
um and it's like I just felt like
everyone was like acting out on behalf
of Beyonce and Beyonce was like you
let's all calm down like it was like
kind of like I felt like she wasn't into
it at all you know it was like it was
awkward yeah that is awkward and I think
it would be awkward to be on the
receiving end of that yeah not even her
like being shy just like being like
trying to act appropriate just like um
just and wanting to just like be a real
person until so it's not like she's in a
room full of like
nobody like yeah like Adele is there
Taylor Swift like and all those hip-hop
Legends like yeah it was weird everyone
really showed up and I I could imagine
that would feel a little weird and it's
like plus she's already getting like
she's making history like we're honoring
her yeah you know everyone also doesn't
need to be like acting like a
two-year-old no and I feel like that's
like Beyonce's life like showing up
places and people like acts like fools
around her she always has to like like
make up for it you know what I mean yeah
like of course the example like of Kanye
and then when Taylor you know then when
Beyonce won an award later on she gave
her speech to Taylor she's like always
like correcting other people's behavior
on behalf of her yeah so I just felt
like she was like kind of like
embarrassed and I would be too it's like
can I just blend in for a second like
yeah I get it I don't know I just felt
like like the whole night it was like
the name on everybody's lips is Beyonce
as it should be she perform no but she
should have totally right because all
the performers were like people who were
nominated for album of the Year album
yeah right yeah that's like how it went
yeah the cheating no no not everyone
not everyone really yeah
oh I guess like Unholy and they're
saying Panic
did not go over well Luke Combs was not
um he was not nominated for album of the
year no huh and I thought we'll get to
it we'll get to it next best country
album winner
let me tell you the nominees yes Ashley
McBride Queen Luke Combs obsessed Marin
Morris love Miranda Lambert would take a
bullet Willie Nelson so all of the
nominees were in the room except for
Willie let me say something because this
is absolutely and the winner was Willie
Nelson this is no disrespect to Willie
Nelson and I think country music in
general you know as most genres try to
do like they really pay so much respect
and homage to those who came Legend to
the Legends and to those who came before
them and I'm sure Willie Nelson's album
is good it's this is not you know taking
anything away but like I don't think you
could take away from Willie Nelson bffr
be [__] for real like come on you're
kidding me right like I don't know first
of all to give it to someone it
shouldn't count like whether you show up
or not but you know this is an
entertainment show and there were people
there for the same reason they spread
out all the awards to everyone would
make like a viral speech yeah
I mean I was so rooting for Luke Combs
but like honestly I would have
understood when the category was
announced I was like [__] like Luke is
has some steep competition like anyone
could win except for really like except
really like he's nominated like out of
respect but I was like it could be
Ashton McBride it could be Miranda
Lambert it could be my Mars I was like
good luck Luke no honestly Miranda
Lambert her album
is incredible like she and if anyone
else would have won I would have been
like you know what I'm sad I would have
been like okay but I respected yeah like
Luke didn't win I loved it but like it
wasn't Luke's time for it to be Willie
Nelson I would just love to know like
what those artists like think of this I
know
um also I feel like the Grammys like it
just felt like they didn't even
listen listen to any of the albums it's
like they looked at the list and it's
like oh we know William Nelson and he's
really talented and I feel like now
thinking back like they do that also
with Chris Stapleton he wins everything
and the thing is he's so worthy so you
don't question it but it's like what
about the other people who actually
deserve to win but like I don't think
like this was the only country music
category was the only country music
performer and like I don't think they
even listened honestly no I I could see
that I could see that definitely being
the reality it was really upsetting
honestly because it just feels like
every now and then they'll just like
throw a curveball to be different which
we'll get to for song of the year
um and it was like at the expense of my
artists you know Taylor lost because
Bonnie won and Luke lost because Willy
won and not to make everything about me
but it felt like a personal attack no it
felt like so disrespectful honestly and
like Luke is there didn't care and Luke
so like Luke is and just the sheer fact
that like Luke Combs doesn't have a
Grammy he's now lost six times wow It
it's so flawed yes but I take solace in
really believing that Luke doesn't care
about the Grammys that Luke has
everything like you know he's so
grateful happy and I think he goes to
the Grammys because it's cool and it's a
sign of respect and like it's another
right and like he gets to it's a great
concert but I think it does not chip
away from him whatsoever to not have a
Grammy no for sure but like you go you
want to win
yeah I think for for 15 minutes it's a
bummer yeah we're all human even Luke
Combs it's shocking but it's true
his performance was beautiful I actually
maybe it was because I like put him
later in the show like please disrespect
me more some of us have a bad time
um I waited so long Bootleggers yeah
want to go to sleep I don't know if it's
because I waited so long for the
performance and then like I just felt so
defeated after it because it wasn't even
a worthy loss like if he had lost to
Miranda Lambert or Brandy Carlisle like
I would have been Ashley McBride I would
have been like okay random other
nominated so yeah she should have been
um I would have been like okay you know
what was meant to be but because it felt
like he really was robbed really
everyone was robbed
um
it felt like his performance was even
more emotional for me like I literally
ended that song is so that's one of your
favorites on the album It's So
spectacular I actually found myself like
getting choked up like I just loved it I
love this man yeah
I love this man and the Grammys like
didn't care about him they acknowledged
him because they had to not because they
wanted to and I feel like that's the
recording Academy in a nutshell like
they'll there are people who they can't
ignore and they just like have to give
them like a nomination or a performance
and then there are people who they just
like literally industry plan like lift
up and like you're like who the [__] is
this person yeah
and but then it also begs the question
it's like what does a Grammy mean
is it you know art is subjective so is
it who they think is the best song
because then you really can't argue with
who they chose but Does it include you
know success
Does it include popularity what what
it'll be helpful if they told us
what the criteria I'm sure they do
somewhere yeah best pop duo or group
performance Sam Smith and Kim Petras
Unholy that was so clearly going to win
that song is taken over and like I
like pride myself on the fact like I've
been a Kim Petras fan like before it was
cool
the way I [__] hate that song like it
really oh my God I hate it maybe I don't
know why I hate that song oh my God I
like it but I never listen to it is why
probably I like it so when I hear it
come on I'm like yeah
but then after they won I put it on
because I was like now I'm craving it
and I listen to parts that like you know
I don't hear on Tick Tock or reels and I
was like oh it's just a song yeah I
don't know what it is about the song
that like made it go so viral but I'm
happy for Kim Petras I just I really
don't like that song yeah oh wow shocker
and I don't really like that dance that
goes along with it that like it's all
sedans it was he did it on stage they
did it on stage Sam Smith and then it's
like all over Tick Tock it's like the
coordinating dance and he's like taking
little steps and he's like oh sorry they
I'm sorry
it tastes like a little step he did a
tic-tac-to on the Grammy stage yes right
and it wasn't like you know say so yeah
yeah it wasn't a song that like Anna
dancer took over the world yeah I just I
mean I just I hate that song okay you're
allowed yes I am best musica Urbana
album Bad Bunny clearly winner I think a
lot of people also thought it would be a
bad bunny sweep yeah it was not no but
he had the he opened the show yes and he
won for his album and he's extremely
good looking like I'm sure everyone
knows that but like I don't really
listen to a lot of a lot of music so I
don't like see his face a lot and I was
I was enjoying what I was seeing for
sure I said you know that's a nice face
yeah people are saying he looks like
Brody Jenner that's what [__] be with
you said and and I saw it that's also
what Morgan Stewart said oh that's so
funny actually that's a great call um
best rap album Kendrick Lamar could I
think I guess that one I also liked his
speech where he was talking about like
the little tables and the wine yeah he
was like shaving it he's like it's nice
but it wasn't nice no yeah it was very
easy at a little table it was like
informal it was
yeah tables were so little you know and
then the table but I was seating charts
was interesting it was sitting with who
like the Adele lizzo table was
everything the Combs is in Miranda
Lambert obsessed
and they probably had a really good time
yeah um Taylor got her own table because
she had like Jack engine off tree
and Aaron Aaron desner obsessed tree
you looked like Taylor Nation Queen her
publicist who like literally like
revitalized Taylor like seven years I
didn't see Jack there and he didn't want
to bring his fiance he won maybe there
wasn't seat at the table his table is
too small they were tiny um he won
producer of the year so he was like out
and about you know doing press and stuff
coming and sitting
um Coldplay sat with someone so Random I
couldn't I just remember thinking Nicole
black Chris I was just thinking like hmm
that's weird and wonder what they were
talking about yeah it was uh it was fun
to see who was sitting with you if I
could be seated at any table it would be
with Adele and lizzo for sure oh it
would be the common season oh [__] yeah
wait you're right
um best dance electronic music album
Beyonce Renaissance and she was there to
accept it and that made her the most
awarded Grammy person artist of all time
um James Corden was the one who gave it
to her James Corden made a funny joke
cracked me up no it was I was cackling
in my bed it saying and you know I'm
like so hard to laugh in these
situations he said I'm here to announce
the winner of the electronic best dance
best dance electronic album because of
course I would be I'm the perfect I'm
gonna put on everyone's a lady yes it
was a cat it was honestly funny because
it's like yeah first of all if this is
the one that like Beyonce was gonna make
history for like why James Corden why
wouldn't it be like someone connected a
little bit to Beyonce to like James cord
and everyone's like ugh but then the way
Trevor know what was bothering me so
much I'm like you know what I don't
think I would mind if James Corden was
doing this job Miss James Corden but
maybe it's kind of like you hate the one
you're with kind of yeah yeah absence
makes the heart grow fonder so there was
actually some drama around this category
the first was that um they cut to you
know some of the losers one of them
being Diplo and Diplo people believe
they're reading his lips saying they
bought that
I see I thought he looked happy for them
I I actually I I believe that like the
read lip like looked like like on point
like they bought that huh I don't
believe it that they bought it or that
he said it that he said that that's what
what he said I don't think you can buy
Grammys which is why it's like steal
something that's so soft there's a way
that you could like there's definitely
you know back channeling but I don't
think that like I don't think that's
what happened here like she was up for
album of the year like it was the best
dance like yeah and he looked happy to
me I'm not like I'm not I'm not falling
for it no you know yeah falling for it
the other kind of like drama controversy
was like a lot of people were mad like
that this was considered a dance that I
could understand I was just reading the
other people who won I'm like oh they're
really like Rufus just electronic and so
I could understand that gripe I can too
because people don't see Beyonce as a
electronic dance artist but if you
listen to the songs it is electronic
like it's also pop no you don't see yeah
it's pop
I guess but this is a this is a cool way
of you know
being the best in the category yeah I I
thought it's like how the redheads is in
arts right in the podcast store and to
be honest of all the albums on there
it was the only one I really hadn't
heard of so yeah no it makes sense why
she won the category but now I'm
questioning why she was in the category
right right right maybe they bought her
way into that category I don't think
that's what he was saying but I also
don't think he said that because I'm not
falling for it okay don't don't fall for
it I'm not forcing you to fall no you're
not you're not I'm just letting you know
like what's going on on social media I
know but I'm just saying like we're
always wrong not we social media is
always wrong and they always jump to the
worst conclusions about people it was a
nice man it's fair and I don't think he
thought he was going to be Beyonce okay
song of the year oh okay no sorry best
pop solo performance Adele easy on me
she made a sweet speech there were tears
um and you know what I can even though
her album like wasn't 25.
um her performance on easy on me is is a
wonderful pop solo performance and you
know what when it came out there was a
seismic shift in the universe like
people were not okay yeah the song is so
gorgeous and then there was the easy on
me challenge right so it was good
that I didn't have questions about that
me neither
then Luke performed then I turned off
the show it was so then my the sister's
shot was blowing up and you and everyone
was like someone was like what and I
didn't know what happened because no one
said what happened guys were just like
reacting to it oh song of the year
Bonnie Wright just like that
so some of the other notable nominees in
this category Adele easy on me Beyonce
break my soul Harry Styles as it was
lizzo about damn time Taylor Swift All
Too Well 10 minute version
any single one of those people could
have won and it would be CR it would be
it would be right yeah it would be
justified I of course was rooting for
Taylor Swift All Too Well but if anyone
else had one I would have been like you
know what it was the song of the year
like I would have been able to
understand it
now
this I don't understand I don't
understand at all and so before I dive
in I just want to say this is not a you
know takedown of the song or Bonnie or
her career the song is really beautiful
there's like a gorgeous backstory to it
you know her son passed away and gave I
was an organ donor and gave his heart to
someone and she ended up being able to
meet the guy who got her son's heart and
he was like do you want to lay your head
on my chest and like feel your son's
heartbeat like and she was like in that
moment I'm gonna write a song about this
like so there's a beautiful backstory
behind it it's a gorgeous song but by in
in no Universe was it the song of the
year and this is a category that's not
best song it's the song of the year
meaning best performance right pop solo
performance so this category is like
what was the song of the year like when
we look back on this year when we see
the song of the year we'll be like oh
yeah I was listening to Harry's house
while I was you know getting out of
quarantine you know what I mean like
so it's not a subjective category it's
not you know who did they think was the
best if it was maybe we'd be able to
rationalize it a little bit more
the silence
mostly because the first lady was the
one who gave it out and she said just
like that she didn't say the person's
name so we didn't know if she was done
talking or not and there was like a beat
of Silence
and just like that it was over for
everyone else it was confusing she just
said she literally open the envelope
just like that
Bonnie Raitt like right it was it was
done weird and so I think there was a
silence because of that but also because
everyone's like the [__] you know but if
she said Bonnie right then it would have
been like okay Bonnie write one but just
like that it's also just like a phrase
like did she just say a phrase yeah no
it was it was confusing for sure
um oh my God and it was very awkward and
you know Bonnie is a queen like she's a
PG house she had literally never in a
million years thought she was gonna win
like yeah because she shouldn't have
action because she shouldn't have you
know what was her speech she she
couldn't talk she was like honestly like
I love to write songs and like thanks
like it was sweet but like bffr be
[__] for Real come on like I really
want it all too well to win I don't know
if it was necessarily the song of the
year but it was just such a feat you
know it was such a
it's so different it's really not like
anything else on that list it's a 10
minute song it is uh deeply well written
in profound song so that's why I was
rooting for it but honestly as it was
was the song of the year you know yeah
so was which lizzo song was about 10
times I also to be loved is like also
one of the songs
um as a person a little zoomed out it's
about damn time about damn time
literally was the song of the year like
I could make the argument for anyone and
so we all just sat there just kind of
like bad habit is that one bad habits no
that's Ed Sheeran and that is confusing
no
um Nails it's a bad habit it's very
tick-tocky okay then they take back what
they said why that like it should have
been up there no no it shouldn't have
been up there
a b c d e f u I'm glad it wasn't I think
that's what it should have been that
would have made more sense the vitriol I
feel for that song
like you hate this genre that I love of
like pop rock like
and it's like Tate McRae I love Tate
McRae you do love okay
Leah uh okay 10 Things I Hate About You
Hate That Song Mimi Webb love
so what's up I saw you out he was I
don't find Tay McRae and Mimi Webb to be
in the same category as a b c d e f u
okay
like to me that's a kitschy silly dumb
songwriting okay
fine that's fine as long as like we
could be listening to Tate McRae still
you have quarters so I just I really
don't even know what to say about this
song of the year because I don't want to
be rude she's a nice lady yeah like the
[__] no get real Jackie it was so
awkward like I'm so pissed I missed it I
watched the whole show and that was the
most interesting part and let me tell
you why it was even weirder she
Jill Biden gave away two Awards this was
the second one okay the first one was a
new category they're introducing song
for social impact you know I think we
had a story that they were introducing a
category challenge for social impact
which took us to
um send it on on and on it's not too
late to you know posthumously give that
they could do a re-recorder
reach your heart just one spark starts
the fire with one little action a chain
reaction will never stop okay let me
tell you why else it was so weird do you
want to finish you look like it's
busting out of you
foreign
tell me why it was weird because this
was the second award she she did for a
song of the year but then before that
she did song for social impact and she
explained that it was being given to you
know a person who made a viral video on
Tick Tock I'm so sorry I do not know his
name
um who wrote this like beautiful
original song at the peak of the Iranian
protest like for women's rights
um and it you know kind of became the
anthem online of this movement yada yada
and you know instead of you know
presenting him the award she said
um well he's in jail now now for song of
the year and it was so weird because
honestly like it really uh highlighted
this element of like out of touchedness
for the Grammys in general and then
there was like this commercial they had
afterwards for the recording Academy
that was like these are like our they
had all these headlines they were like
fake headlines it was like protesters
and police put down their weapons and
listened to music together
um it was getting like Pepsi commercial
energy
um it was like you know lawmakers you
know enact laws after hearing song about
women's rights like it would and then
then the recording Academy CEO comes out
he's like these aren't real headlines
but they should be
it was so cringing out of touch and then
right after like it's like so this guy's
fighting for his life in Iranian that's
[__] real right he's fighting for his
life and Iranian prison like fighting
for like things like rights like um
fighting against human rights that we
could never even imagine and we're over
here giving him a Grammy be like oh well
he's in prison but he has a Grammy
Claude right no it was so he has a
Grammy it was so beyond
out of touch like
I think maybe perhaps a great way to end
it if we had to give you know the guy in
prison uh an award would be like and
here's how we can help get him out like
yeah you're literally sleeping next to
the president do something like it was
so but like I can't do anything but I'll
give him this award it was so I'm like
I'm like when she said but he's been
arrested I was like what I'm like are we
gonna go get him like I can't do
anything but like you literally can I
was like this is beyond it was so and so
then just to transition that like
awkwardness into record song of the year
there was weirdness you know yeah and
then for song of the year to go the way
that it did it was just honestly it was
kind of like a bad showing for Joe Biden
like it was just it wasn't her night it
really wasn't
yeah damn it sounds like everything got
interesting when I turned off the show
100 that commercial somebody tweeted it
was so true it felt like you know when
SNL does those like pre-recorded fake
commercials yeah it was one of those it
was so moronic that's so funny also need
to talk about a few of the performances
and the new idea of bringing lay people
um to a round table to Advocate I'm so
glad you brought that up to advocate for
their favorite artists and why their
favorite artists should win an album of
the year because when that you know when
the show was already going over 45
minutes I'm like well the first people
to go with the fans you know like cut
them they didn't
um and it was like three packages
throughout the night because there were
so many albums and so many fans
um and the way I was not okay I was like
this is [__] moronic
Until the End okay so Harry won did he
get to meet the great grand so they when
well I'm talking [__] I'm investing okay
I'm only invested in the grad no I was
invested in the Grand and I was saying
like she has to meet him he's right
there she's obsessed we all had the same
experience like we all only cared about
the grand
um so star great grand
so when they were doing album of the
Year Trevor Noah was the one to present
it and while they were doing the
nominees he was like honestly fans come
up here like you deserve to be up here
while we announce it Jesus so they all
insane by the way wait no but look they
all came up and stood behind him in a
line and he said and the Grammy goes to
and he opened it up and then he went
over to the fan
and she was like you said and she was
like
bereft
Harry Styles and then they cut to Harry
and you know what it was so dumb like
the whole time leading up to it but
until that moment I was like you know
what this is actually mad cute like we
got a good moment at the end of it
because she and then Harry got on stage
he gave her the biggest hug kissed her
on the cheek like spoke to her for a few
seconds before he made his speech so it
it came full circle but the journey to
get there was not okay but also only
because it was the great grand and Harry
like I feel like if it was just like one
of the other super fans at the gym
artist I'd be like can you go to a meet
and greet like yeah no get out of here
no totally totally so that was something
I also felt like Harry Styles
performance was not very good and I I
thought everyone would be living for it
and I was just being critical but like
in the first like break and he's like on
the microphone he like rocks out so hard
I'm like it doesn't call for that yet
like I felt like the energy was being
put on his
energy was
I couldn't find it it was non-existent
this man is not okay when like all the
walking I'm sure it's symbolizing
something maybe you know how life can
just hamster wheel
hamster wheel but then it comes back you
meet someone you set them free if they
return his vocals his vocals were not
great his energy was really lackluster I
think energy was fake to me he was doing
and then it made me feel like all those
other times in like Tick Tock videos
where he's like on a concert like I'm
like has that all been fake no because
that's the thing like I've seen so much
footage of Harry on tour and he really
like he gives it like he is such a
performer and I've never once felt like
he was tired while he was up there
because like we joke like he needs a nap
but you know every time he gets on stage
like he does the damn thing and he has
like so much energy he doesn't stop
dancing and singing and his vocals are
always on point like he doesn't miss a
note so to watch this performance where
it felt like he had literally no energy
and every time he moved he was like
literally using his last three brain
cells yeah but he was also like faking
the enter the classic Harry Style stuff
which I I but it feels authentic when he
does it I know he's capable of Faking it
and so that kind of just like
it kind of
like ruin the magic ruin the magic yeah
but I think look that was the first time
I'd ever really felt that way and I
think it like it looked visibly
different than like his concert footage
you know what I mean yeah I just feel
like he was like not in a good mood and
he was like tired and I feel like he's
not okay I mean he did a show at the
Forum on Monday how was his speech very
low energy as well he was just like
really Shook and he was like thank you
so much he's thanks to the appropriate
people he was like you know I just can't
believe this things like this don't
happen to people like me and like he's
getting dragged for that it's like
things like this don't happen to be like
you like perfect looking gorgeous
talented Rockstar like I always have an
angel no it's like okay
okay I know what he's saying but he was
working in a bakery he's not like a
nipple baby like he literally
show he started from the bottom no and I
totally get it but it's like so you know
what it does doesn't happen to people
like him no like I don't see Kelly
Clarkson winning album of the year no
it's so it's so true but like just
hearing someone who looks like him say
that it's like you were like literally
born perfect no I know but like I get it
you don't know his struggle no of course
not of course and you only saw the the
spotlight yeah but you didn't see the
time in the dark no
um but it wasn't like an overly like
emotional or energetic speech got it and
then um other performances the hip-hop
tribute was really incredible which was
so awesome and it was so cool to see
everyone like having a good time jump
out of their seats out of their seat on
their feet singing along like doji cat
lizzo Jay-Z yeah it was sizza okay like
I might like sound really dumb the way I
did not know Queen Latifah like was like
a rapper or a singer I was shook to my
the only thing that they needed was
um a thing at the bottom like saying
who's coming on next yes because like
very fast it was very fast and but some
people like on you but also Zach I was
watching with Zach so some people that I
didn't know he just like was telling me
who they were but I was like the Grammy
should be telling me yeah because also
there was a different performance the
one with happy chanuka
um
and they had a thing at the bottom of
who it was yeah I'm sorry Smokey
Robinson could be the most accomplished
man on Earth and to me he will always be
happy chanuka the man who didn't know
what Hanukkah was who did a cameo
wishing someone a happy Hanukkah and he
said happy chinuka and he said what's
that chanuka it's the best video it's
honestly precious like I would find it
offensive it wasn't so funny I'm
obsessed obsessed
um so I did not know Queen Latifah was a
performer like I was not okay because
for me like when I was young and like
was introduced to Queen Latifah she was
in her like rom-com era like beauty shop
just right that dumb Steve Martin last
holiday that's holiday like I like
that's my familiarity with her and so I
did not know she was amazing she like
looked I like know her as like more like
maternal like she wears like like just
like sweet like kind of like old lady
dresses
um but seeing her out there like with
her cargo pants like I was [__] I was
obsessed like I was living for it I was
not okay then I knew this person was a
rapper but I know him as a detective in
the NYPD iced tea I don't think I've
ever actually seen him perform lived for
it for me that was the part that I loved
the most about the like people coming
out of the woodwork who we know for
certain things yeah but have a history
uh you know of a legacy in the rap
industry I didn't know it was it was
really great and I thought all around
ever almost loving life yeah having a
good time having a good time which you
love to say the in memoriam was so
beautiful so long it was really long but
Casey Musgraves um did they just break
it out differently or were there more
people no they broke it out differently
they did three songs I feel like you
should have one person sing a really
long song for the home in memoriam but
this time they had three different
performances with three different
slideshows it was long but was that
because there was more people no no like
they were being slow everyone still gets
the same amount of seconds but there was
like there was a decent amount of people
who needed to be on and some a lot of
people need to be honored in a big way
like Loretta Lynn and like take off
um like people who were like you know
more
front-facing the Fleetwood Mac
um person front-facing then you know
some uh people who are more on the back
end of the music industry but Casey
muscular's performance of Coal Miner's
Daughter by Loretta Lynn was first of
all like one of the most beautiful
things I'd ever heard in my life and
we'd love to see a queen out here
respecting the coal miners no now that
I'm kind of like in Appalachia
um you know an honorary Appalachian I
have a I like really that song really
touched me it's it's a touching song
like I was like so enjoyed to hear it
and her voice sounded like it was she
didn't miss one note one another it was
Perfection yeah that was great show Crow
kind of stuck it up not to be a [__]
but I wasn't watching for her I don't
know I think that's when um
I don't know I said to go out
um okay let's continue record of the
year
lizzo about Dan Tyme deserved deserved
and she needed to get her one award yeah
Best New Artist Samara Joy okay so
obviously I had never heard of this
person um but the whole category I
really don't know except for lotto and
Anita and you know it's not main skin
it's like meniskin
I'm being dead serious okay fine because
there's like a there's an accent over
and I can say I don't know how that
should be pronounced so I have no idea
who Smart Joy is but when they when she
won her music started to play and she
literally sounded like Etta James like
she's like jazz like gorgeous it was
gorgeous
um but I I often feel like meniskin is
the only one that I've heard of but I'm
not saying they should have won just
because I've heard of them no me and
they came from Eurovision I just really
thought Lotto should have won
like like I feel like people don't
realize she's literally on like every
song they like you know
I I don't realize okay that's correct
new artists like always confuses me like
and they they almost like they don't get
it right usually in terms of like who's
gonna have the most long-term success
like if you've looked back on people who
have like Celine Dion like lost Best New
Artist you know what I mean yeah they
they're kind of like always off it's
like always kind of a flop yeah and then
album of the Year Harry Styles Harry's
house
it's like that's that's the most sense
it was the album of the year it really
was
what did Theo think of the Grammys loved
well he just loved it like the the whole
family was watching together like oh my
God I'm so glad everyone's witnessing
this because buruno is the most jealous
no they they're both oh they're fighting
now if someone's sitting on someone's
lap like the other has to get up there
look Bruno come here no Bruno like no
one can be with Bruno's mommy other than
Bruno yo come here
yeah no you come here they're so jealous
like they're they're they're bitter
Rivals these two no I know feel kind of
smells like
okay that'll be fun bath time with my
boy um so that's the Grammys recap we
could talk a little fashion if you want
to sure I loved what Casey Musgraves
were even though I was just like a
little that's Jackie that was my like I
couldn't even see what she was wearing
so I was like is it Balenciaga I
attracted I tried to look it up but I
couldn't find nothing else I know how
could it not be so what you were
financiaga that's kind of weird too
Jackie I tried to look it up and I
couldn't find like
that's atrocious I know because that's a
statement I I know
I thought the same thing so I have a
problem with that yeah and honestly like
Kim wore a year and a half ago I'm not
impressed yeah like you're like even if
it's you know
Balenciaga yeah I didn't think there
were any like truly remarkable I did not
like what Taylor wore it was giving very
much like what the advanced girl wears
to prom do you know damn do you know
what I mean no it's like sheena's
wedding dress yeah I did not like it but
she's so radiant she can't look bad so
like it didn't matter she can't look bad
she looked really beautiful but it
it wasn't anything new or exciting Adele
is like the queen of the matronly dress
and as someone who like tends to dress
like older than I should like I get it
but like she's gonna switch it up like
it's so like Grandma you know what else
I hate I hate people who change their
outfits in the middle like I understand
you want to change for your performance
but like pick one dress I bought people
make choices not oh I like these three
but I can't choose so I'm gonna like
keep changing while you know there's a
commercial break and nobody's even
looking at me yeah it was like cardi B
did not need to change I'm sorry but she
was Far and Away the best rest amazing
on the red carpet and I didn't like what
she wore to present and like I wanted to
see that dress again and like you're
wearing the best dress of the night yeah
stay in it the second dress was fine it
didn't bother me but the First dress was
so
like the way cardi B wasn't nominated I
don't think for a single thing and she
stole the show in that dress she was the
best dressed agreed she looked so
gorgeous and like really the dress like
so complimented her body in the best way
she just looked gorgeous I just like
people should choose a dress and stay in
it yeah aside from their performance if
you want to you know put on your cat
suit yeah but then get back in your
dress Liza wore this like big dumb
jacket but the dress underneath was so
cute and I almost wish she like
literally just wore this dress it was
like this orange corseted bedazzled
dress and then like this big dumb Big
Bird thing it was a mini dress no it was
all the way it was a gown let me look
because I saw like the whole ensemble on
the carpet but I didn't see her speech
so I didn't see
um she didn't wear when she wear
something else I don't know actually
what did she wear to she yeah she wore
something else oh yeah she turned it
into the silver thing horrible it was a
lot of dress but the orange this dress
is horrible yeah the orange thing okay
on the carpet with the jacket but the
thing underneath was like actually very
beautiful I see the thing underneath and
I think if we had seen it on its own we
would have liked it
it wasn't like an amazing night for
fashion if I'm being honest no
no Beyonce I liked her outfit
I don't remember it was like gold like
it was like gold yeah yeah silver I
guess like everyone's saying silver yeah
that's what they're saying that's what
they're saying I don't know if I'm
listening no but you know me I could be
a follower if need be no I'm I'm gonna
follow cardi B I thought JLo looked
amazing me too I don't think she walked
the carpet because I didn't even know
she was there until she just walked out
as a presenter and this Bedazzled look
it was like a kaftan it was gorgeous and
with the hair the hair the hair was
really something I that hair is going to
become like a go-to celeb inspo pick
like for people bring to their dresser
hairdressers for their wedding it was
really gorgeous really gorgeous oh
Kelsey ballerini looked really good but
I didn't see her aside from in this
Yahoo I saw her on E she looked radiant
Marin Morris what about Shania Twain we
do need to talk about Shania Twain she's
not okay no she's not okay and I would
have thought she was even like less okay
but then she knew everywhere to everyone
I know I thought that was funny I love
that for her but what was with the wig
I'm glad she presented because I feel
like other celebrities would have been
like
not knowing who she was on the floor and
they're like okay yeah no totally the
hair was so nuts but then on the carpet
the big dumb cat was even more dumb I
don't know like I'm all for you know
being playful especially like I feel
like when you get older they're like
that's kind of discouraged like I'm
really I'm all for being playful but I
wouldn't want to see a young person in
that wig the Hat was more for me like
really upsetting it's really upsetting
Doja cat I don't love her red carpet
look but I remember seeing her in the
program I thought she looked amazing
she's really kind of like such a she's
such an IT girl yeah
um Marin Morris horrible oh really
horrible I like it she'd bleached her
brows which you know if I didn't have
naturally bleached brows I would think
was so ugly but because like you were
born this way self-hate yeah like I love
it I like it too
Camila Cabello cute what was she doing
there not winning anything or being was
she even not she's not made in once yeah
she had like front row seat in the
middle like that didn't make sense to me
how like Coldplay Chris Martin was like
all the way in the back Luke Combs
Miranda Lambert and Camila Cabello who I
think like was nominated for one
category for like duo with her song with
um
yeah that's just life baby
um with Ed Sheeran like she gets front
top billing front row Center she's the
best seat better than Taylor
because they knew she'd be in her seat
the whole time
Savage you know like you don't have to
worry about when she goes to perform a
seat filler right or a win or a win oh
and then the last thing that made my
heart warm was Dwayne Johnson who
started talking and I was like
whatever he's saying oh about how he got
a guitar from Willie Nelson I was like
we don't care yeah we're mad at Willie
Nelson and then he said you're welcome
oh he did he said he was talking about
how he sings off key I said again we
don't care and then he said you're
welcome oh my God I was freaking and
everyone in the audience who like has
kids was not okay yeah it was kind of it
was kind of a moment it was a moment and
I forgot that he's Maui and he sings
like he's on one of the most fire albums
of the century oh yeah I can most you
know phenomenons yeah
what can I say except you're welcome
Bruno was finally sitting on the third
chair in the studio like which is my
solo chair and it's like why haven't the
boys thought about this sooner because
they want a piece of us they do they're
obsessed
um before we continue on I would be
absolutely we absolutely have to move on
because imagine that like you didn't
watch the Grammys and you don't care
well it could be me well welcome back to
the show and the rest of the show that
you hopefully care about is brought to
you by all birds when it comes to
Quality Mother Nature knows best and you
can take that idea and run with wool
Runners from all birds this year trade
your synthetic Footwear for the wool
Runners crafted with premium
Supernatural materials that are comfy
and durable from all birds you can run
to the ends of the Earth or just to the
store or the liquor store if you're May
wool Runners are built using premium
Supernatural materials with a low
environmental impact so you can get Next
Level comfort with zq certified super
fine Merino wool that's temperature
regulated moisture wicking and itch-free
something worse when you got like
sneakers on like an itch at the bottom
of your foot
so the sugar cane based Suite foam
midsoles Contour to your feet and put a
little bounce in your step the caster
bean insoles are cushiony and naturally
odor reducing the shoes are machine
washable so they look as fresh as the
first day you got them and they are
designed to be versatile and stylish
because your feet deserve better than
becoming Billboards for Brands I have to
say wearing shoes like I wear sneakers
almost every day wearing shoes that you
know you can throw in the washing
machine is like provides a level of
Peace like that you don't have to I can
step in this mud like it'll be fine like
you don't have to constantly be thinking
about your shoes like your shoes should
be like a barrier of protection for you
and I throw mine in the laundry machine
like once every two weeks and it's
fabulous it's so comforting it's so
useful it's so great for a sweeper such
as yourself I'm constantly sweeping most
Footwear Brands Overlook natural
materials for cheaper more synthetic
Alternatives but all birds is using the
highest quality materials whenever they
can and if there isn't an alternative
that meets their standards that they
take things into their own tents and
invent their own this year take a big
step forward from Mother Nature with the
all birds wool Runner discover your
perfect pair at allbirds.com today
that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s.com today's episode is
also brought to you by ZocDoc no more
trust no more Dr roulette or scouring
the internet for questionable reviews
with ZocDoc you have a trusted guide to
connect you to your favorite doctor that
you just haven't met yet millions of
people are using zocdocs free app to
find and book a doctor in their
neighborhood who was patient reviewed
and fits their needs and schedule just
right
so whether you've done it it's true
millions of people whether you've just
moved like you have I use doc doc down
here because I need all new peeps by the
way I use ZocDoc up there too because I
decided like two weeks ago I absolutely
have to get a check up like I cannot
remember the last time I went to it I
don't even have a GP I don't have like a
eyebrow general practitioner I've been
going to the pediatrician like my whole
life
um so I found one on sock talk I made an
appointment online with the insurance
like it was so easy yeah you can like
tell them insurance location what kind
of doctor you're looking for and they
give you just like options yeah and then
most importantly you get to make a
choice yeah so there's no like alarms or
surprises that you get there and like
they don't do your insurance like it's
all done for you also don't have to like
be awkward and like call and like ask a
million questions which is heaven on
Earth yeah
um so whether you know you're just moved
or you're just ready for like a new
dentist or whatever it is or you need
like a specialized dermatologist check
out zocchoc it gets rid of so many like
the awkward social interactions around
finding a new Doc because I really don't
know if you move to a new city where you
don't know that many people you can
always get a recommendation like if you
have a ton of people but like how did
people find I don't know doctors in new
places before talk because literally I
don't know what I would be doing go to
zocdoc.com toast and download the ZocDoc
app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com toast
zocdoc.com
toast I'm kidding toast it's confusing
it is especially when you're being dumb
like me okay our first I'm sorry our
Second Story second and third are some
new couple newses okay that are
interesting because our list things are
moving around on our list okay ASA
Gonzalez is seen on a date with Ben
Simmons who is Kendall Jenner's ex but
not like the ex not yeah not the most
recent serious it's not a big deal like
in terms of Kendall yeah it's just like
a fun fact that he dated Kendall but
like like that's why we know his name
not because he's like LeBron James you
know yeah that's why we know his name
but like people who know basketball yeah
do know his name
um a source exclusively tells page 6 at
the Brooklyn netstar oh I guess he's a
Brooklyn player now he used to play in
Philly has been dating the actress Aiza
Gonzalez for quote a few months but the
pair has been trying to keep their
romance a secret they've been hiding and
trying not to get seen together however
on Friday the new couple was forced to
go public when Paparazzi spotted them
out on a date night in New York City
they were photographed leaving Bond
Street a high-end sushi restaurant in
Manhattan where such good crispy rice
we're told they dined with a group of
friends they weren't alone for the
dinner but they are very clearly
together The Insider said so a few
things like she looks she is gorgeous
and this is how you know they're dating
because that's what you wear on a date
yeah like looking sexy Selena Gomez at
the bowling alley so true I have to say
Isa Gonzalez is not dumb like no I feel
like she's really done like an amazing
job she's super talented and she gets
booked on great roles but there's so
much more to like becoming an A-list
celebrity actress right than just the
roles that you book and she like plays
the game hard like [__] that Josh Duell
moment I mean we she popped on the scene
to Liam Hemsworth of it all like she
really like does well romantically and I
think she has a lot of fun while doing
it and this is another great get for her
um she does need like a breakout role I
think that's the one thing she hasn't
had yet there's a lot of speculation I
think literally that you started that
she might be playing
um
Evelyn thank you no there's not
speculation it's me saying Aiza Gonzalez
needs to play but it's all over Tick
Tock too people when they like their
Dreamcast she is like one of the top
that actually like hurts our chances
because that never happens yes no it's
true but she needs like I feel like
she's had really good momentum I feel
like for a while people have been saying
like she's the next big thing but like
it has to happen yeah I agree with all
of what you said um it also helps that
she's absolutely gorgeous she's the next
level it helps like you know oh she's so
nice we hung out with her remember at
the Super Bowl she's a lovely girl she
is and she has great style look at I
just can't get over this picture of her
and she gets booked on like really good
A-list roles I feel like she's always in
like Oscar movies and stuff but she's
never like this the breakout Sensation
from it and she needs that I think she
should keep her on this trajectory she's
always at the Oscar she's adjacent yeah
okay she needs a moment we she does and
Evelyn Hugo like could be that moment
yeah um I'm glad she's finding love but
this does mean that her and Jason Momoa
are no longer right canoodling because
they were rumored on and off they were
on a motorcycle they were in London at
the same time going into the same
restaurant and I guess she's moved on or
maybe this is her like you know he
didn't want to get serious with her so
she's gonna go like be out at town with
some like hot New York basketball player
and just to make him jealous and then
he's gonna be like you know what I
really fumbled I [__] up he's gonna
say azai messed up come back he's gonna
say Come Back to Me Mama and she's gonna
say I'm sorry Jason it's real with Ben
what we have is real but it's not it's
all just so like she's playing the long
hand
so smart she's so smart I love her
totally are you ready for our next story
which is also some new celeb news and
it's just like
people person from here person from
there okay Ashley Benson oh is dating
throwback Brandon Davis oil air who
dated everyone 10 years ago okay like
not to be so annoying I literally
I just saw these two together I was with
them
and I didn't know he was like of no
person
because everyone was like do you see
them like they're dating I'm like oh
like I literally didn't care so like I
could have spilled this tea already you
know what's crazy I think if you came
home and told me like oh Ashley Benson
is with Brandon Davis I wouldn't have
cared but seeing it like this I care
like I just told them at a party they
were clearly a couple and like it meant
nothing to me who is this man so he like
dated Paris Hilton back in the day and
he was like a big part of the drama with
like Lindsay Lohan and he was like one
of those like oil heirs who was just
dating all the girls okay in 2006. I
don't remember like and like we haven't
heard from him since and now he's dating
Ashley Benson he's 43 just to give you
like a taste of like when we were right
right like 10 15 years ago yeah maybe
more now yeah and so actually been so
Random to me random right so Random yeah
like
okay when you think of the Pretty Little
Liars girls like who do you think has
done this I love this conversation it's
been six months so we could have it
again so when I think of like the
biggest success I think of Shay Mitchell
do you agree yes then I think of Lucy
Hale yes then I think of I don't know
it's a tie for last yeah try and like
she's I think it was at the Royal
Wedding like she doesn't have a career
she doesn't try to keep action she
doesn't have a career but she has a life
yeah you know happy life yeah and she
does like a lot of activism like she
does a lot of like eating disorder stuff
and she has a she have a baby yeah and
she married what's his name from Suits
and she went to the Royal Wedding I
think she's like a deeply happy
fulfilled person yes so I will put her
third maybe even second like Lucy the
thing about Lucy Hale is like is that
for a lack of trying like Lucy Hill
tries out for everything she like gets
all these TV shows he has like a few
movies a year that come out and flop
except that one that came out um that
was based on a book The Hating game or
something loved I watch everything she's
in I love her she's like one of my
favorite yeah but you happen to like
love
flops that's so true you're literally
floppio it's so true what is that do
they flop because I love them or do I
love them because they flop I think you
love them because they thought you're
like an empath you know it's just like
why does everything I love flop
maybe honestly like not to be not to be
mean maybe you have bad taste no I I you
know what I don't think so and you want
to know how I know because of like
triangle of sadness like if that's what
doesn't flop and that's just critically
acclaimed then I am just like an outlier
of the culture and I'm you definitely
are an outlier of the culture by the way
okay with that and I'm proud and I'm
proud you know Lucy hell will never be
in Triangle of sadness no much to her
dismay but like that that's why she I
should go back to the ranking I think
like we might have to put her lower
because it's not for lack of trying they
train but like Luciano acts more than
Troy and betraying doesn't even try no
but like Lucy how much you follow her on
Instagram like she has Brand deals she's
so like brand safe and she's always you
know on a red carpet here she's like the
face of Avon she's you know going to
Fashion Week and she's always dressed by
the brand like she really is a celebrity
who has like all of the celebrity things
happen endorsements yeah by the way I
get told
all the time that I look so much like
Troian Belisario I do you do but not in
the same way that you look like Victoria
Fuller like Victoria Fuller and Troy and
Bella don't look like but you look like
both of them I just want to say not to
be so toxic like as long as I'm being
compared to skinny brunettes like I'm
okay oh yeah because like I don't want
to get you started on yeah no comparison
I have a lot of I have a lot of thoughts
on like celebrity doppelganger slash
comparisons if you saw my show not like
other girls am I stand up you know and
if you didn't see it my special will be
coming out soon so you'll be able to see
it anyways Ashley Benson and Brandon
aren't trying to keep their Love Under
Wraps they've been spotted together
numerous times over the past couple of
weeks Claudia apparently saw them until
she can confirm and they were on a
double date recently with Emma Roberts
and who her new man's Cody John cute
cute
um let's see like young Hollywood going
out for double dates I feel like we
don't see double dates a lot no but like
we should I feel like everyone has
everyone over to their house yeah and
we're never getting like inside so it's
so wrong so wrong
um happy for them hope this works out I
have a feeling it won't not to be
negative yeah that's literally today's
title I keep saying mean things like not
to be negative
but sometimes it happens no but
sometimes like you've got to be negative
I feel like negativity like kind of gets
a bad rap you know sometimes it's
necessary and sometimes it's funny yeah
and sometimes I think positivity can be
like really toxic
phony baloney I completely positive
people are like so [__] annoying no
and like they're not they're the darkest
meanest people you've ever met they
suffer they suffer and they'll make you
suffer for their positivity
phony
agreed are you ready for our next story
what's up in the final is it no okay
it's Fourth and penultimate
and this is gonna love when you whip out
your SAT words this is a really a
penultimate story because it's like it's
a big one okay before we come down and
we bring you back with the Fifth Army
Hammer is speaking out uh two years
after he was accused of sexually and
emotionally abusing multiple women he
has given a new interview with who with
the digital newsletter airmail I just
want to say I'm glad like he obviously
wasn't able to get a legitimate Outlet
to
to sponsor his comeback tour because I
feel like
um
okay I want it in my sentence there
sorry I don't want to continue I'm glad
he couldn't get like you know variety
yeah but the variety is the publication
that's written up his interview in
airmail that's a fun
that's where we got our air mail
air mail
it sounds like um like a newsletter for
frequent Travelers yeah I know you get
it like when you're in the sky yeah
anyways he's actually saying some
serious stuff and says that he was
sexually abused by a youth pastor at the
age of 13 and he contemplated suicide
after the rape allegations that
torpedoed his life he says two years
after he faced a series of sexual abuse
allegations that ended his career as a
movie star Army Hammer is attempting to
tell his side of the story in a new
interview he reveals that he
contemplated suicide after his downfall
sometimes that is downfall sometimes
that Long Island accent what's up on you
what is that downfall
go dogs I hope the dogs have a downfall
and claims okay this isn't Penny okay
but like I didn't mean to say just it
was funny you can acknowledge the Vlog
back to the seriousness he claims he was
sexually abused by a youth pastor at the
age of 13. he denies all criminal
wrongdoing but admits to being
emotionally abusive towards former
partners he had met on the internet sure
the actor who was accused of having
cannibalistic fetishes now says that his
interest in BDSM originates from being
sexually abused by his youth pastor when
he was 13 years old he said quote what
that did for me was it introduced
sexuality into my life in a way that it
was completely out of my control I was
powerless in the situation I had no
agency in the situation sexuality was
introduced to me in a scary way where I
had no control my interest then went to
I want to have control in the situation
sexually he spoke with the digital
newsletter airmail and told his side of
the story for the first time airmel
reported that hammer told two people
about his childhood abuse and the
publication states that it did
corroborate his account with his
godmother
um
I have two things to say so I he talks a
little bit just about some of the
accusations and how his life was
unraveling and he contemplated suicide
he said quote I just walked out into the
ocean and swam out as far as I could and
hoped that either I drowned or was hit
by a boat or eaten by a shark then I
realized that my kids were still on
Shore and that I couldn't do that to my
kids he talks a bit about the
relationships with accusers Courtney
cabbage and Paige Lorenz and he
acknowledged that the power dynamics
were off admitting one million percent
that he was emotionally abusive towards
both women he said quote I would have
these younger women in their mid-20s and
I'm in my 30s I was a successful actor
at the time they could have been happy
to just be with me and would have said
yes to things that maybe they wouldn't
have said yes to on their own that's an
imbalance of power in this situation
he's like so intentionally taking
responsibility for like none of the
illegal things I mean he's not gonna go
on he there's an investigation into him
he's not going to go on and admit like
he shouldn't be doing an interview I'm
just saying first of all like being a
victim of abuse is horrible but it is
not an excuse no it's not an excuse
um but it this is true that this is what
happens to people who are abused as
children like you know grow up and a lot
of times like become abusers themselves
I understand really it's messed up and
it's really sad and that doesn't mean
that that abuser shouldn't be held
accountable because like there's someone
else who's suffering and it's a cycle
it's a vicious cycle but like
there's an origin I know but you know
someone like Armie Hammer who has like
enormous wealth and privilege like it is
on you to break the cycle like it is on
you to get help you have access to all
these things that most people don't have
access to like I don't know I just
it's not an excuse so to to admit that
you're a victim of abuse to kind of give
context as to why you were abusive but
then only take responsibility for your
emotional abuse which is obviously
bad but it's not as worse as physical or
sexual abuse like this is like such a
cop-out to me yeah
yes I mean I think he's admitting to as
much as he could admit to for me like
you know there's there's not really a
coming back from this so it's I think it
it definitely gives context to the story
to know like what his experience was I
don't really care honestly but
um yeah that's just okay so so that's
why you did what you did but you still
did what you did he said quote I'm here
to own my mistakes take accountability
for the fact that I was an [__] that
I was selfish that I use people to make
me feel better when I was done and moved
on I'm now a healthier happier more
balanced person I'm able to be there for
my kids in a in a way I never was I'm
truly grateful for my life and my
recovery and everything I would not go
back and undo everything that's happened
to me
okay bye
go like like I don't know what he thinks
like this is gonna start like some sort
of comeback no one's interested like go
back bye yeah
but I'm glad that he's getting the help
that he so desperately needs because
like even though he's you know On The
Fringe of society he could still be
harming people wherever he is so I guess
yeah I personally don't care it's on him
like what he thinks himself yeah but it
was always on him to fix himself so now
that you got dragged you're like oh oh I
need to heal but like you needed to heal
always and it's it's on all of us like
whatever your trauma is like it's on you
to heal that trauma yeah so that you
don't pass it on to others whether it's
abuse or whatever it is and that's why
it's so also important to stop
pedophilia in its tracks because it is
something that is a cycle right
so
yeah that [__] needs to stop but it's
like not going anywhere it's like bigger
no no people don't care yeah but then
okay Fifth and final story a little
lighter fair is it a little lighter Fair
that's brought to you by DraftKings
Sportsbook oh my God look at us because
we're the premier Sports show so of
course it came to us whether you're a
football fanatic or you're just tuning
in for the Super Bowl 57 action
DraftKings Sportsbook is an official
sports betting partner of Super Bowl 57
and is the place to bet new customers
can bet just five dollars and get 200 in
bonus bets instantly plus all customers
can get in on the Super Bowl 57
excitement with DraftKings happy hour
super boosts check the DraftKings
Sportsbook app every day between 6 pm
and 9pm
EST for daily happy hour bets so you
know we've been going back and forth a
lot who we're going to pick for the
Super Bowl honestly I'm not sure yet do
you know
oh my God it's so hard because I really
want to root for Jason but I also want
to root for Travis no I want to refer
Jason but I don't think I can root for
the Eagles I'm so sorry I know by the
way I'm experiencing the exact same
thing like of the two brothers like I'm
definitely more of a Jason girl I think
that makes it good because then whoever
wins like I'll be able to find like so
happiness in it like the eagles do win
I'll be like oh my God Jason I'm so
happy for you and if the Chiefs win I'll
be like the Chiefs I'm so happy for you
if you've never bet on the Super Bowl
before DraftKings is the best place to
start very true download DraftKings
Sportsbook app and use code toast where
new customers can get five dollars on
Super Bowl 57 and get 200 in bonus bets
instantly it's only a DraftKings sports
book with code toast minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply C show
notes for details and um again that's
DraftKings Sportsbook app code toast
thank you so much turdy yeah that's
really permanent information as we head
into Super Bowl weekend 100 it's by the
way we didn't talk about the Super Bowls
yeah super week super week I'm really
excited for the Super Bowl what are you
gonna eat everything no for real like I
don't know because I don't even know my
plans yet I think I'm gonna make nachos
usually the Magnolia table cookbook we
made them up for Thanksgiving game day
and they were so good so recipe on Tick
Tock that's hella cute what for like how
you it's really it's not a recipe it's
like chips
guac salsa whatever but how you um
prevent it present it it's like you make
it into a little field and like it's
really cute I'll send it to you who has
the time does it look time it didn't
look hard at all okay send it to me I'm
open to it
Fifth and final story peacock releases a
statement after Real Housewives ultimate
girls trip incident with Brandi
Glanville and Caroline Manzo an
investigation was launched into an
incident that led to the early exits of
Brandy and Caroline from the real houses
of ultimate girls trip season four in
Morocco it enjoying statement to people
represents representatives for peacock
and shed media broke their Silence about
what happened during the filming of the
second installment of the franchise's
Ex-Wives Club format in Marrakech at the
end of January quote the Safety and
Security of cast and crew while shooting
is extremely important and we take all
reports seriously in this situation
production immediately launched a
comprehensive review and is taking
appropriate action people was the first
to report about Brandy and Caroline's
departures which according to insiders
occurred after Brandy took things too
far with Caroline during a party kissing
her multiple times throughout the
evening without her consent it was
unwanted a source that at the time in
Caroline's distress over the matter did
not seem to stop Randy things escalated
and physical boundaries allegedly were
were crossed that Caroline felt were
serious and uncomfortable following the
incident the decision was made by
production to report what happened to
higher ups filming continued that night
and into the next morning when Brandy
was made aware of Caroline's feelings
and apologized via text message still
the decision was made that afternoon
unbeknownst to Caroline to remove Brandy
from the trip early Brandy's Behavior
was inappropriate as a third Source said
so she was asked to leave later that
night Caroline decided she didn't want
to film anymore and chose to exit the
show on her own she needed to process
this outside of the reality TV
environment the first Insider said I'm
just like shocked that the rumors about
what went down were actually true I feel
like we're always getting like
fraudulent information when it comes to
Housewives yeah this is really crazy I'm
shocked that Caroline left because they
protected him before they took her side
um and Bernie needs to leave it makes me
wonder if
Brandy like was being an appropriate
crossing boundaries and Caroline reacted
and then wanted to remove herself from
the situation yeah you know because like
honestly and Brenny like is wild wild
sloppy
mess like someone were oh are they
trying to kiss me like that and like
just and it was I can imagine the way
that she can be sometimes like I think I
might get physical yeah if my physical
boundaries are being crossed like I
could see myself
throwing a hand yeah yeah I could no I
mean it's so out of control you know
Brandy Glam feels like such a Loose
Cannon and that's why everyone loves her
but she's always really really cool it
only takes it too far to crossing a line
no no she always crosses the line no
she's like a wine glass yeah when she
slapped Lisa Vander yeah she always
crosses the line yeah she does but this
feels different than both like this is
especially because this is a sexual
assault her and Caroline must have met
like two days before and my god did she
choose the wrong [__] like literally
Caroline Manzo like would never
literally like some of the women like I
feel like on OC they always used to make
out like some of the women are down like
whatever to get freaky but she shows a
wrong [__] like Caroline Manzo not only
is so not like that she'll kill you like
what are you doing yeah it was a really
dumb decision and I feel like Brandy's
just using these ugt opportunities to
make herself known again and maybe like
one day get back on Beverly Hills and I
think a lot of people want that for her
and they loved her in the Berkshires and
she's just setting herself back with
[__] like this she's such a liability
and she's really a and I love her but
she's like [__] like this really just
reminds us like of how tacky she is and
this would never like this just is not
the Beverly Hills Vibe those women would
not be filming with her no with behavior
like this like it's just it's disastrous
yeah
um also it reminds me of that Cameo of
hers that went viral did we ever talk
about it like eating vagina or something
no no she was making a video for someone
who was getting married and I don't know
if she was drunk I mean I hope she was
because she was just like don't do it
like marriage is the worst like it was
it started as like yo you're getting
married why like it got so dark so
quickly it was insane yeah no that's so
Brandy it was insane she's not okay yeah
um
but you know what I'm glad that
Bravo handled it in a way like I feel
like Bravo sometimes lets a really
[__] up things just like they chalk it
up it's like oh ladies being ladies and
it's like actually you know what that
person did or said it's like actually
extremely not okay and I could see them
like literally letting this go because
they're so next they'll address it on
the show right they just like allow such
poor behavior and they almost encourage
it yeah well it's a double-edged sword
because like that's what makes the show
go around but like there is a line yeah
no this is definitely across the line
I'm glad that they suck because I could
see them just like ignoring it yeah or
just letting the show play out you know
Brandy they made Brandi leave and then
like Caroline left and they would just
put that on the show but you know what
actually the fact that they put out a
statement makes it much more enticing to
me as opposed to just like rumors yeah
so I can't say I'm going to be watching
this but um but there's still another
season first if there is a um like a
video of you know the incident of the
incident when the episode airs I think I
would watch that yeah I mean just keep
in mind we're talking about ugt Morocco
ugt Thailand still has to come out
that I can tell you I won't be watching
no it's like they we know so much about
it when it's happening because like the
fans are obsessed and there's so much
that comes out about the women in the
area I think the women like who are
really want to make it a thing like they
I think they share with fan accounts
like what's happening yeah for sure like
they're leaking stuff so it's like we
get to invest it as it's happening and
it doesn't come out for so long like
we're still waiting for number three
yeah that's crazy it's crazy it's so
dumb
um so those are the past five deals out
you needed to know it was kind of like
the fast like four like one big one you
know yeah yeah the slow one the four
were fast yeah the one was last was long
um and that is our show hope this Monday
you know carried you through to lunch
time that's really all you can ask for
us and now we have to ask ourselves the
hard question of what's for lunch for
lunch it's so hard to figure out lunch
here like when we're together like we're
always on different levels we had that
idea for the wrap we did have that idea
for the brand I think we have the card
today let's go we're gonna go get a wrap
I love we're gonna wrap it up rip it up
rap that [__] up I said Hey sir can I
get a grilled chicken Caesar wrap that's
what I'm going to say when I walk into
the cafe
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe and give this video
a thumbs up we're also available podcast
anywhere podcast can be found Spotify
iTunes sister public radio I already
castbox all the places podcast
Tuesday and we'll see you tomorrow
goodbye